These are the heroes and demigods of modern
capitalist mythology.
We tell and retell their biographies while
venerating their awe-inspiring works.
If there is such a thing as “winning”
the game of life, most people would say this is it.
Our media is fairly obsessed with entrepreneurs,
whether it’s Shark Tank inventors, celebrity
restaurateurs, march-hawking bloggers, or
makeup tutorial moguls.
We’re bombarded with messages that suggests
that entrepreneurship is the only path to
real wealth and fulfillment.
Everyone feels the pressure to quit the day-job,
reach for the stars, and be your own boss!
But as any successful entrepreneur will tell
you, it’s not for everyone.
The autonomy and independence can be fulfilling,
but you’ll probably be working longer hours
for less money—at least at first.
And having a great product idea or visionary
artistic talent is just one small element.
Whether you want to be a freelance graphic
designer, an Instagram influencer, or the
inventor of a squirrel-shocking bird-feeder
(oh it’s a thing…look it up), most of
your time will be taken up with new tasks
and duties that you may or may not find enjoyable.
So before you quit your 9-to-5, let us show
you some of the many hats you’ll have to
wear if you want to be your own boss.
So, you think your cupcakes are the bomb and
decided to start your own business?
Congratulations, you’re not just a baker
anymore.
Now you’re a CFO!
Cash is the lifeblood of any business and
no matter how much people like your product,
if you’re not balancing revenue and expenses
correctly, your biz will bleed out.
The two main skills a CFO needs are Budgeting
and Accounting.
Budgeting is deciding how to spend your money
to get the most bang for you bucks.
It means being realistic about what you have
to work with, and eliminating waste wherever
possible.
If you’ve never kept a personal home budget
you might want to start to get some practice.
Accounting is minding your business’s financial
records, which includes tracking your income
and costs, estimating your quarterly taxes,
and maybe even payroll.
You’ll probably have to learn an accounting
program like Quickbooks, or maybe hire a bookkeeper
to lighten the load.
But most entrepreneurs will tell you that
you’ll always have to be involved.
No one will care about these numbers as much
as you do.
In addition to being CFO, you are also now
the head of your company’s Human Resources
department.
That means you’re in charge of hiring, firing,
training, delegating tasks and responsibilities,
as well as figuring out payroll and benefits
for your staff.
What’s that?
You don’t have a staff yet?
Yes, you do: yourself!
Leaving a salaried position means finding
your own health insurance, selecting your
own retirement plan, and picking up the slack
for payroll taxes that you used to split with
your employer.
When it is time to bring on employees, finding
talented and dedicated people—and keeping
them happy—is essential.
Many entrepreneurs credit their success with
being able to attract and retain employees
smarter than themselves.
There are lots of awesome books and podcasts
on assembling and managing teams, and we’ll
make sure to share our favorites in the doobleydoo.
As a supervisor, you’re not just a manager
of people, but also of time.
Time is money, as they say, and making sure
that neither you nor your employees are wasting
it is crucial.
Our friend Chelsea over at The Financial Diet
wanted to give her two cents on the biggest
lessons she’s learned when it comes to managing
time.
So here's what I did wrong when I first made the jump to being an entrepreneur.
I tried to force a "normal" schedule.
It made me feel like I was working harder if I forced myself to work into that 9-5 even if that wasn't
when I was getting my best work done.
I would save the "easy" little things for last because often when I didn't have a fixed timeline throught my
day that meant just pushing off the tasks that I didn't really want to do and felt like I could do later.
And the third thing I did wrong was forcing myself to have bigger chunks of "offline" time.
Essentially, taking weekends and vacations as the time when I would totally unplug.
And this is how I fixed them:
Instead of forcing myself to fit into a 9-5, I leaned into the times that I did my best work.
And in many cases, for me, being a night owl that meant getting work done at night when my brain was thinking
its best.
The fact that you're able to set your own schedule, as an entrepreneur or self-employed person, is something
you should take advantage of not fight.
Secondly, I started doing all those easy little things FIRST thing in the morning because I found that
when i got them right out of the way I felt accomplished and that sense of accomplishment snowballed
into being able to take care of bigger and bigger tasks. And plus all that little easy stuff didn't keep
falling to the bottom or get kicked down to the never slot on my to-do list.
And lastly, I started spacing out my offline time giving myself dedicated chunks, even throughout my day,
where I was away from my computer and specifically forcing myself not to work.
When you don't have dedicated work days and vacation days you can constantly be pressuring and guilting
yourself into getting more and more work done.
And ultimately that leaves you more drained and unproductive
So by dedicating those offline times throughout my day and throughout my week I was often feeling refreshed
and not like I had to force every minute into a work minute.
The next hat you’ll wear is a big one: Marketing
Director.
Attracting customers to your brand is an enormous
job!
You’ve got to conduct market research, create
& test advertising, design promotional materials,
manage social media accounts and more!
And no, a few random posts on Instagram aren’t
going to cut it.
Marketing is a complicated, multi-layered
discipline that involves statistics, psychology
and art.
If you’re lucky enough to afford it, you
can hire a specialist to help you, though
many small business owners have to figure
it out on their own at first.
Luckily, there are plenty of free resources,
like this episode on Market Research we did
a few weeks ago!
For many new entrepreneurs, the hardest realization
about marketing is that the job is never done!
Even if your product is a stone cold hit,
you will always have to keep reminding people
about it!
Even Coca Cola still advertises.
Once your head of marketing has attracted
a bunch of potential customers, it’s time
for your Salesperson to seal the deal.
(That’s you again.)
If marketing is your public image, sales is
your personal relationships with customers.
Being a good salesperson doesn’t come by
intuition, but by honing and practicing skills,
like active listening or networking effectively
in a room full of strangers.
You’ll also need to learn how to roll with
rejection without taking it personally, and
how to create a repeatable step by step process
that nurtures potential customers all the
way from initial interest to the sale and
beyond.
And finally there’s —
— wait…”finally!?”
There’s so much more we haven’t talked
about!
There’s logistics, customer service, legal!
Not to mention hard-to-nail down “soft skills”
like keeping yourself motivated and dealing
with irregular income.
I know, I know, but while we don’t want
them to have rose-colored glasses, we don’t
want to totally scare them off!
Honestly, so much of this can and will come
with time and experience if you have the fortitude
and patience.
And if this doesn’t sound like it’s for
you, that’s okay!
For many people, having a solid day-job that
they enjoy can be more fulfilling—and less
stressful—than wearing all these hats at
once.
And that’s our two cents!
Thanks to Chelsea for contributing to this
episode.
For more fresh takes on personal finance you
can subscribe to the Financial Diet on YouTube.
If you've started your own business what was the best piece of advice you received?
Be sure to share it with us in the comments.